foreign
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel uh today
I have a special reaction okay I'm gonna
be reacting to the Tristan Tate
interview that just came out but before
I start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
in
um let's get started also guys I will be
reading
super chat's over like I don't know 20
bucks 20. we'll see
um so if you have something you want to
say make sure you send it in a Super
Chat I'm pulling it up on my phone now
so just give me a second
um you can pull up the video though
all right guys Tristan Tate exclusive
now this is exciting because I know so
much about Andrew Tate like we react to
him all the time but we don't know as
much about Tristan
so let's find out why did you get banned
why did you go to jail
[Music]
I'm fully aware that I would not have
been banned or canceled if I wasn't
Andrew's brother
if I had played things my way me and
Andrew would probably be back in jail
[Applause]
I jumped off the walk I'm not scared
Jake
you want to send me back good because if
you send me back you're now gonna have
to explain to the world why
can they even do that like what is the
crime every story all the girls it's
only towards Andrew they don't care
about the truth they just don't spin
some negative story they wanted to take
Brothers in jail
it's us against the world
[Music]
so when you hear the war Tate you think
about Andrew Tate but it's
really the brothers Andrew and Tristan
Tate and when I think about Tristan Tate
I I told him earlier I said you could
have gone a complete different ride the
guy looks like a Hollywood star he looks
like a movie star uh he looks like he
could have played James Bond maybe they
shouldn't even consider it unfortunate I
know they just made the announcement he
looks like a real James Bond dresses
like one
um has the personality of one the ladies
love them if you've never seen his
pictures just go on Google type in
Tristan Tate you'll see what he looks
like the looking guy but
he's got a completely different identity
to himself very different than Andrew we
had a very good time talking to Andrew
uh your brother and the way he built you
up today was very unique I've seen you
guys talk to each other about each other
but the way he did it today was very
different anyways Tristan it's good to
have you on the podcast it's good to
finally yes last time we met in Madrid
but we never did a podcast for about 60
seconds I was saying I was eating
Spanish paella the night before I
cracked one of my teeth and the next
morning Andrew wakes me up saying okay
let's go to Patrick's podcast and I had
this big swollen face so I hid inside of
my hotel but I did catch you for about
45 seconds by reception because we were
staying in the same place yeah and you
thought I'd been in the fight I thought
because you guys fired I'm like this guy
probably gotten too far you know
apparently now I know he lost her some
muscles but not the good kind of yes
yeah not the good kind so here's my
question for you when we read the
stories about why you know Andrew's Gone
to prison or Andrew this or this woman
came out or that woman came out why did
you go to jail why did you get banned
why did they take your Instagram down I
mean I remember the pictures it was all
cars and suits and motivational stuff so
is it Guilty By Association it is Guilty
By Association I hate to say it but I'm
fully aware that I would not have been
banned or canceled or probably ended up
in jail if I wasn't Andrew's brother but
there are so many benefits that come
with being Andrew's brother that you
have to take the good you have to take
the good with the bad so it didn't it
didn't upset me too much no I smiled
about it what does this positive
attitude come from you could be the
victim oh Andrew you you did this yeah
you landed me in jail look at all our
assets are seized yet smile on your face
as gracious just humble guy where did
all this come from you know it's always
been the way me and Andrew are and we've
shared in our successes the first time
he became first time he became a
millionaire we celebrated when I became
a millionaire we celebrated when um you
know we bought our first Supercar we
drove that home from the dealership
together so every single positive moment
in my life the first time we ever
charted a private jet I remember we were
just happy drinking having a great time
on the on the plane this is before he
reverted before anybody jumps on that
drinking reference but if you want to
take all the good moments from having a
relationship a brotherly relationship
like me and Andrew have and then he
becomes the world's most Googled man one
of the most influential men I guess in
in the world and by default he's
attacked by The Matrix in a way that
ends ends up with him being thrown in
prison I feel like I'd be more mad if I
didn't go to prison with him I'd feel
like you know I've taken all the good
from being associated with Andrew and
you know he builds me up and I build him
up and for him to be sitting in jail
without me it would just feel wrong so
I'm not even mad about I don't the
opposite of mad about it I'm glad they
broke me in but I'm glad they said
Guilty By Association I'm glad they
throw me in jail with them and if they
frame him for real and send him back
they better send me back too or I'll
break myself in
doing something like that but you did
give a good book recommendation earlier
I appreciate that which was great it's a
inside joke but uh uh yeah so going back
to this whole story of uh I got confused
right now because you know we're both in
a different place yeah I'm thinking
number seven I'm thinking eight and a
half I'm in a whole different place
today okay well working out is good
staying in shape is good you know all
that stuff is very good thing so really
though when you talk to your lawyers why
why did you why did they put you in jail
I mean I know it's Guilty By Association
can they even do that like what is the
crime every story all the girls it's
only towards Andrew where are you
involved yeah well when digging through
Andrew's entire past trying to find a
reason to put him in jail what you have
to understand is
we have not been accused by X number of
women the prosecutor has accused of us
of doing X to X number of women these
women actually defend us actively one of
the statements in the file is a girl who
I used to date a little bit she details
nothing illegal says nothing illegal
went on she wasn't held against her will
she wasn't trafficked she wasn't
exploited but
because I used to sleep with her I guess
I'm guilty too so I mean I guess one of
the girls is my ex so that's the only
real link
um with me but I have said this so many
times okay I've said this so many times
I wish I could go to my father
and say that I lived in a mansion
rent free
did Cam work
and now somehow I am a victim
I wish I would I wish I might have would
look look at me like I'm the dumbest
person on the planet I swear to God he
would
but it's crazy how these girls can make
any accusation they want
and now they haven't been free in six
months and the crazy thing is like
didn't we didn't I thought there was a
report that said Tristan had like a baby
or Aunt one of them had a baby that was
born so they didn't even get to see the
kid the first couple months it was born
so yeah it's just wild he's guilty by
association they wanted the tape
Brothers in jail so when they came when
they came to arrest and they come to was
it was it you and Andrew it was both of
you yeah they had arrest warrants for
both of us and when they came to arrest
us what's very funny is my cousin's
girlfriend was here at the time with
with her friend there were actually
women in the house at the time the women
in the house were not questioned the
women in the house were not asked if
they were okay the women in the hospital
asked if they were in danger if they
were safe they were completely left
alone left to sit on the couch with us
um while the police watched over us well
they went through the house and took
everything that was valuable they were
Googling the value of the various items
they were taking marking it down on a
spreadsheet and they left I think
without saying a single word to the
women who were in this house which is
very unusual you would think an
investigation about human trafficking
but you know you could you could take
what implications from there you will
and uh guess what their motivations were
if you will but I'm I can say anything
at the moment that makes sense so uh we
talked to Andrew earlier about his
experience in jail how was the
experience do you think if they're not
guilty they'll get their money back and
they're stuck that's crazy that they can
just literally take all their throw
them in jail because one girl said
something and this guys this really
shows just how women are just
automatically believed in this Society
they can make up anything and men will
have real legal consequences imagine if
men could do that to us imagine if men
could accuse you of something with her
no evidence get you locked up for six
months
and take all your that would never
happen and if it did there would be an
uproar but for some reason with women we
just automatically believe them it's
like okay there are good men and there's
bad men
and there's good women and there's evil
women
and so why don't we just acknowledge
that that there are evil women that want
to do evil things and you know honestly
the worst female emotion is spite we are
the worst version of ourselves when we
are spiteful I think in the same way
that men are the worst version of
themselves when they're really angry
like when you have a guy that's like
super super angry
um like he'll do things maybe out of
character right that's why I'm pretty
sure I talked to a
um
it's like 10 I forgot during what period
but there was a period in history where
10 of our ancestors were literally
murdered ten percent not nuts so so what
does that tell you it tells you that
when to the ex when you allow men to act
to their extreme right they're capable
of crazy things and so what we have is a
government that takes women at our worst
because let's be honest when we're when
we feel wronged from a breakup that's us
at our absolute worst like we that is
the worst we will ever act and you allow
us to legally ruin a man it shouldn't be
allowed just like when a man's super
angry you shouldn't legally give him the
right to kill somebody but yet women can
throw a guy in jail
and take all of his
when we feel like we are wronged and I'm
sorry ladies are our feelings
our feelings trick us they deceive us
we're the easily deceived Bunch that's
just what we do
well I mean Romania spends less money
per prisoner than any single country in
the year
the the prisons are constantly getting
in trouble from the European Union for
being uh underfunded uh too many people
per room not enough square meters not
enough calories per day so the jail
experience
it wasn't good but it was interesting
and I took jail on a very strange way I
feel like
if you're gonna if you're gonna walk
around the world running your mouth all
the time about what you are and what you
think you are eventually something's
going to come along in the world and
test you if you walk around saying I'm
the baddest man on the planet I can beat
anyone up on Earth one day something in
the street is gonna be like ah you're
the guy who thinks he could beat anyone
up and punch your lights out
you know I don't speak as much as Andrew
but I do say I'm a very strong-minded
person I always preach to young men if
you're going through hardships you know
you need to deal with it like a man
continue your training stay focused and
it just felt like God gave me an
opportunity to prove to to myself above
all else as well as to everyone else who
listens to me that I am actually what I
say I am so coming out of jail I'm
almost grateful for the experience as
hellish as the environment was
as hellish as the environment what you
were grateful for yeah I'm grateful that
my life has been very very easy for the
last
six or seven years I retired from
professional fighting when I was 28. the
last sad thing that I guess happened to
me was my father passing when I was 26
and a half so I'm 34 now I'm coming up
35. these things happened a very long
time ago I've increased in wealth I've
increased in Fame I fly around the world
doing whatever I like driving whatever
car I like staying wherever I like
sleeping wherever I like going you know
it's been such an amazing experience
that I haven't tested myself for real in
a very long time so yeah grateful for
the experience and Andrew and Tristan
have such a good mindset I would be so
pissed I would be fuming
fuming if this happened to me
yeah they have they have a very good
attitude about it we've had very high
praise about you right I mean we did we
did a whole segment about someone says
I'm the worst version of myself when I'm
hungry that too that too guys he always
thought you were the best brother in the
world but after being in jail with you
now he knows he's confirmed and
reaffirmed that you're the best brother
in the world and he almost kind of
compared you to like being the the Ying
to his yang right I didn't really fully
understand who Trista was we've sat with
Andrew for hours on end we just had 45
seconds with you yeah after that uh
paella incident right
um but he says that your special gift is
the man you've mastered the art of not
giving a yeah what is that all
about well I'd say it's not not giving a
in the way that because I know
people who don't give a their life
sucks you know they don't work out they
don't care about their their own health
happiness wealth work uh not in a
degenerate I'm a bum kind of way I'll
give you a better example I know exactly
what he means I feel like because I am
his younger brother every great General
who sits at a table with his staff needs
that one Fearless guy with it you know
he needs people who preach prudence and
being careful and we have those people
believe me they're very very loud in our
ears every single day since getting out
of jail but you know if you're a great
Samurai General and you're sitting
around the table you also need that one
guy who says okay there's 10 000 of them
there's five of us okay let's just go
it's more fearlessness than not giving a
if I if I had played things my way
since getting out of jail me and Andrew
would probably be back in jail right now
I'm censoring myself on this podcast but
the first day I got out I thought you
know what screw it just put a camera on
just tell the whole world what's going
on let them take me away live on stream
that's me so luckily he keeps me in
check but also I feel like I can Inspire
him to make a few Bolder and braver
decisions in life because of my counsel
so I'm very much one of his councilmen
but he doesn't need me at the table
without that guy you're just going to be
a you know have you always played
the number two role like you know in in
monarchal times it was always the eldest
son that the pet was passed down to the
crown from your father down to Andrew to
you has it always been an understanding
all right I'm Number Two my brother's
the leader let me get in line let's
crush it you know I I don't feel
it's necessarily it's necessarily like
that I feel it's more that I know what
his strengths are and I'm there to
compensate for his weaknesses he knows
what my strengths are and I'm there to
compensate for his weaknesses so who's
the leader and who's not all depends on
the situation that we're in
um certainly with
I mean me and Andrew have been a team a
very long time and we made a lot of
money before we ever blew up on the
Internet uh our relationship was a lot
more equal then but Andrew is the famous
one I'm fully I'm fully aware that he's
the guy who will go in front of the
camera and say the types of things or
voices opinions in a way that Garner
infamy and fame and I've blown up
alongside him so you know part of the
prices is going to jail you know they
say that uh
your ego is not your Amigo there must be
some part of you I mean you're a six
foot four badass good looking Hollywood
looking guy girls Bugattis yet you're
willing to
take a step back seat to Andrew's Fame
so you must you must have a big ego to
be the place that you're in but you also
have to have
tickets step back and say all right
Andrew you're the guy how do you grow up
with that well yeah with what we're
doing now Andrew's certainly the face of
it but he wanted to build this this was
never my intention I thought okay you're
gonna make some money on the internet
that's cool Andrew you do that I'll
continue doing what in fact I'm going to
interject with another story
there was a time when me and Andrew
could barely pay the rent he was
training and he was fighting full-time
he was a kickboxing one-time world
champion I think at the time and I was
selling Windows I'm a great salesman so
I was bringing home a thousand plus
British pounds per week he didn't tell
you this story did he no he said it was
a window yeah he didn't say he was
balling out making a thousand no I mean
that's not bowling out like I think
these three glasses of whiskey cost
about a thousand dollars but I was
making about a thousand a thousand
British pounds a week uh Andrew had a
previous sales experience I was at the
time working in sales and Andrew was
just living off his fight money so I
would come home every day I said oh I
made this much sales Etc I'll pay the
rent you keep fighting because I was
helping to support his kickboxing career
one day Andrew looks at me and he says
you know Tristan I'm just gonna start
selling for the same company you're
selling for we could bring two three
thousand dollars into the house a week
we'll have a good life we'll make money
and I said Andrew no you can't
you can't do that because if you are
spending all your time chasing sales
leads and knocking on people's doors
like I am then you're never going to
find the time to discover something
better to discover something that's
going to take us out of this crappy
apartment it's going to take us out of
this crappy life so even back then when
I was willing to work away selling
Windows instead of kickbox because I got
paid almost nothing I was the European
champion at my height my most I've ever
got paid was a thousand bucks a fight I
knew that wasn't the financial viable uh
option financially viable option for me
I was willing to sell Windows to let
Andrew continue to have time to train
but also have time to think so now
everyone's like oh well he's the face of
this online Persona and you know you
guys make a lot of money for it I'm like
I'm fine behind the scenes I'm perfectly
perfectly happy I'm not missing anything
from my life with my 2 million Twitter
followers I need 6.8 million to fulfill
you know people will often try to
I guess pit me against Andrew which is
the stupidest idea in the world but
they'll say stupid things to me like
your brother's more famous than you and
I'll say yeah my brother's more famous
than you
like what's the big deal if your brother
was were Mike Tyson for example and
someone said your brother's bare boxing
you you'd be like yeah my brother's Mike
Tyson what you know it's this strange
type of jealousy and envy that I think a
lot of men can't cope with that makes
them drag each other down like crabs in
a bucket if my brother became the I
don't know a billionaire the world's
richest man and I had to stay at this
level I'd be like yeah my brother's the
world's richest man I'd be proud of him
and I don't see anything wrong with that
it's not a competition we're a team I
think that's something but that's the
thing we have such an individualistic
society that that's how people
automatically think they think as an
individual rather than a family and the
thing is like when you're
when you when you have siblings it's
just different you're just always I mean
if you're close to your siblings you're
just always proud of them even if they
do better than you it's just like a
different it's just a different type of
bond I don't know okay so I got an 11
year old son and a nine-year-old son
okay and the perspective
to have there's got to be a also a
massive level of maturity of the younger
one towards the older one I'm the
younger sibling in my family guys the
worst day of my life was when I realized
I had to start listening to my younger
brother that was the worst day of my
life my little brother is like a
natural-born CEO like his personality is
just he's the man in charge so when we
were growing up
me and him did butt heads a lot we both
had so much okay and
the crazy thing was it was like this one
dad just realized I was like I think we
would get along if I just like listen to
him more and stop trying to
boss him around and yeah that was the
day we got along but
it was the worst day of my life
I was like you're five years younger
than me
but yeah he he got to a day where he he
is smarter than me now my sister's six
years older well we got a very good
relationship in our family but the
wisdom of the younger is different than
the wisdom of the older right you're
more watching you're more like okay yeah
that's probably not a good idea I saw
that smack him upside that I shouldn't
do that okay wow that's pretty good that
leads to good praise or that that's good
yeah I don't like that I have no
interest in that oh okay I would have
probably done it this way but I get it
so you have a different optic right to
see different things at what point was
it when you're you know you're coming up
and you you guys are you were talking
outside and you're like Hey we're so
competitive that hey six years ago the
whole prank concept but we no longer do
pranks all this gum yeah we're a big
prank family ourselves
when was it and even maybe from your
pops did that drive you guys to compete
against each other or that the dad drive
you guys to compete against the world
what was his selling point to the two of
you I I don't think it's something that
we learned from my father okay my father
didn't have a a brother or or another
guy in his life who were close like me
and Andrew I think it's something that
happened organically and it's not so
much
competition against each other in terms
of what I can do and he can it's more
like how much am I going to contribute
to the team that you don't so a perfect
example this house is set up literally
perfect perfect for it I'll come down in
the morning 7am Andrew's ass laptop
we'll go do there's an exercise we hate
doing you put 30 kilograms on a burpee
bar do the on a weight bar you do a
burpee lift it above your head and you
do 150 times it's tiring it's horrible
so I'll do it and I'll say you know
Andrew York burpees are the worst oh my
gosh with a bar oh I could never oh I
could never why haven't you done them
yet then he'll do them and then I'll go
do them again just because I know of I
do him he has to do it that's not people
can see it as two men competing against
each other or you can see it as two men
within the same house getting stronger
and pushing each other to become
stronger you know when we're racing
around race tracks we're both I mean I
guess professionally trained drivers we
have lots of track experience lots of
Road experience
the fact that he will drive faster than
me will inspire me to do better in
myself then me and my brother as a team
are better drivers it's not too many
competing against each other
you know it's us against the world but
that's something that happened very
organically and he's always been the
better kickboxer you know I'm I'm bigger
uh by I mean maybe I'm probably fatter
but I've certainly got more muscle as
well but um people see me Smash the pads
and you know amateurs like a girl I knew
once said oh wow you hit the pad so hard
can you beat Andrew in a fight I'm like
no
no when I try to punch Andrew like I
punched nothing I hit I hit air and he
ends up counterpunching so he's always
been the better kickboxer but I could
take that and be like you know what good
he's the four-time world champion good
that's my brother and just be proud it's
us against the world sure that wasn't
that wasn't Pops that was more you guys
it wasn't it wasn't my anything my
father naturally instilled I mean he
certainly wouldn't let us fight and
argue with each other he had some
unconventional punishments we were
arguing he'd lock us in a Cupboard
together to sit there and stare at each
other he told us that story he told you
that stuff
oh my gosh I could never
oh that's such a good idea because it
makes you work it out when I was a kid
when me and my little brother were
fighting you know what's funny
I get along so well with him now but
when we were kids we were just oh my
gosh we would just fight all the time
but
that's a good idea it was a really good
idea and it shows you can tell that they
really like their father really pushed
family and you can tell how important
that was for them to turn out the way
they did that way you know it's true
when you're sitting staring at your
brother because you guys were acting up
and fighting or whatever you might want
to implement someone said I saw you
stop stop I saw were you the one that
said hi to me stop I was gonna say hi
but too shy
okay well you should stop
I gotta I gotta
delete this message you got your showing
my whereabouts
it works you're staring at each other
yes what did you learn about your
brother at that point what do you think
he learned about you just sitting
staring for hours on end as a punishment
I think you just realized that the
conflict has no benefit you're gonna end
up standing in that cupboard that's the
payoff for your hey this is why I say
divorce should be illegal okay because
if you know at the end of the day you
can't get out
there's no point in arguing
thank you very much thank you Victory
competing against your brother
and um you know we grew up in Luton as a
huge Asian
a huge Asian diaspora I guess lots of
Indians lots of pakistanis lots of Sikhs
lots of Muslims and these people work as
a team it's the one of the reasons they
out-compete British people native
British people and almost every single
metric and we knew a guy named Bali
although I hope Andy hasn't told you
this no so he had a he was a lawyer
probably 50 000 pounds a year and he
drove a 400 000 Ferrari I thought 400
000 pound Ferrari and a 500 000 pound
world's worse sometimes and we were
saying like do you think bali's a drug
dealer what do you think he's up to me
and Andrew at the time you know had
quite a close Brotherhood and he looked
at us one and I said Polly how do you
have all this money how do you get these
fancy cars when you're just a lawyer and
you're relatively young he was like 26
27 but five or six years older than I
was at the time and bali's exact answer
was I remember he said you white people
are stupid now I'm mixed race he wasn't
talking anything racial he was talking
about I guess native British people he
says you will have five Sons or your
father may have five Sons which for
someone in my culture he was a Sikh an
Indian Sikh from Punjabi said that's a
jackpot and this English man's five Sons
will all move out of the family home
they'll pay five rents probably to
people like me they'll take five
different student debts out go out five
different career paths they'll they'll
they'll set up they'll get five
different mortgages marry five different
women and never see each other again he
see my father had five Sons now I'm a
lawyer my my brother's a dentist my
father's an engineer my other brother
owns a construction company one of the
and every single skill set that they
needed to to flourish was within the
household so we all live in the family
home we pool our resources our women
work together and prepare food for us we
work uh and every time that we have a
new children or the families expanded we
just expand the house my brother owns a
construction company and that in that
way as a group we have three Toyotas one
Ferrari and one Rolls-Royce and we can
all use them anytime we like
and that was what introduced me and
Andrew because we were flat broke at the
time we had nothing to share uh to the
idea of certainly you know what if we
can buy a Supercar together one nice car
then we can just share that car and now
thanks to his car diction we have I
don't know 40 plus minus the 10 or 11
that means temporarily seized by the
remaining government but um yeah it
introduced us I guess to the concept of
pooling your resources and sharing and
you know what he's 100 right that is a
lesson you can learn from the Indians
from the pakistanis because it's
benefited us massive and you guys live
together here in this amazing compound
it's a really good idea you know my mom
my mom and dad had a similar idea where
my mom and dad bought like um a bunch of
land down the street and each of us gets
a plot of land when we get married so we
can all like live by each other but what
he's talking about is true family is
honestly one of the best ways to escape
poverty and that's why I don't
understand when women will leave their
husbands for financial reasons I'm like
okay now you have two expenses now you
have two rents how are you in a better
place now
now you have one income not two like it
doesn't and Andrew said he foresees
himself living with you the rest of his
days yeah how much of a factor was those
stories from the Punjab guys to today in
Romania you know what that was massive
and I don't speak to Bali anymore so if
you're out there Bali and you're
listening you know thank you for that
um but you know people people will even
ask that nowadays the way that you know
when you're a high net worth individual
the way things are owned is very tricky
you know you don't want you know no high
net worth individual has everything in
his name let's just put it that way it's
complicated the way things are on so
sometimes people will ask me they'll be
five cars on the drive and you know
girls especially who are naive to these
things be like which ones are yours and
which ones are Andrews my honest answer
is I don't actually know let me I have
to look at the papers to work out
exactly what but it but it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter the keys are in
this box in that group and we can drive
them whenever we like and we never argue
because there's so many you know and
when you build that abundance and you
build
yourself to the level of wealth me and
Andrew are at what are we going to argue
about there were times when we were
kickboxing but we didn't have money for
food we used to eat cans of sardines and
there have been times splitting our last
can over plain rice so now people be
like oh that's weird that you share a
house with your brother I'm like it's
weird that you don't
you know I used to share my last can of
food with him and now we can't live in
the same house I've got nine bedrooms
it's not like we're cramped for space
and uh otherwise we just live in two
separate houses with four and a half
bedrooms each and we'll drive to each
other's houses every day it wouldn't
make sense there's got to be 100 trust
for this to work oh 100 which is what
you guys have but me and Andrew have a
100 very obvious yeah very obvious so he
he gave you some love what would you say
about him like from your perspective you
know what what strength who is Andrew to
you and maybe what are some strengths
and things he does that the rest of the
world doesn't see that you know Andrew
is the hardest working man I've ever met
even with the lifestyle he lives now and
as fun as it looks and it is fun and all
the fun we do is real
even if we are in a
luxury hotel in the south of France
where you're paying ten thousand dollars
per room Andrew will be up at seven
o'clock in the hotel gym
he'll message me at 8 30. I'll wake up
next to God knows who whiskey spilled
all over the desk but again that
inspires me and to be like emergency
meeting in my room emergency meeting you
always say that so I'll go to his room
what's the emergency and he'll bring up
tiny issues with the business you know I
could have slept on quite happily but
again it's like me doing the exercise
when he won it pushes me to be a better
person and Andrew will happily work 15
16 hours a day and then go out and spend
four or five hours having fun and
blowing loads of money it doesn't come
from the sky it's not magic we're not
trust fun kids we didn't win the lottery
he is the hardest working man I have
ever met and the fact that I could even
live with him and try to keep up is is
is a testament to me because it's
difficult you know because it's
constantly yeah and people don't see the
work people don't see the work um I mean
me and Andrew we're in good shape I
don't post training videos and you know
Fitness progress videos I just do the
work and let the results speak for
itself in terms of money and in terms of
business and success that's Andrew
everyone's like oh well why does he have
all this money maybe he's a criminal you
know so uh how does he have all this
money I know why he has all this money
because he's sitting right there at that
desk at least 10 hours a day even when
we're not on house arrest he'll be out
in the evenings having his fun and
that's what they don't talk about
um
there is a cost of success like when you
are when you're around like top earning
people it's not like
it's interesting because like people
from a lower socioeconomic status like
if you look in a different perspective
they could be richer and and when it
comes to time right because okay they
have all this stuff but half the time
you know rich people don't even get to
use it like you think because they are
so freaking busy and that's what happens
to like more and more wealthy and the
more and more successful you get is it
starts to be like a money versus time
type of thing and a lot of people want a
lifestyle like that but they don't want
they don't I don't think a lot of people
could really handle what comes with it
and that's what we'll show to the world
this whole hey look at me I'm at my
laptop and I'm gonna grind away for six
hours like that's no one wants to see
that on Instagram no one wants to see
that on social media it's boring they
want to see you driving the Bugatti with
a cigar in your mouth and a beautiful
girl next to you but that doesn't come
without sitting at that desk for a good
while first
when's the last time you told Andrew no
meaning hey I have an idea here's what I
want to do I'm the hardest working man
in the world here's what I'm doing I
have an agenda and you go no bad idea
let's do this instead do you ever tell
him no how does this work in this
relationship I guess the answer to your
question would be tell Andrew no why you
know we're two men with the exact same
vision aiming for the exact same goal
it's that old saying with great power
comes great responsibility so telling
Andrew no you have to understand I'm the
only person in the world who can tell
him no ever since dad died it's me and
that's it so I'm not going to use that
power over something trivial over
something that is a recommendation if I
don't think he should do something I
just know when he really really
shouldn't do something and then I'll say
no but I can't I literally can't think
of an example
I can't think of an example where I've
told Andrew no in the last couple years
that's the dynamic of the relationship
I'm between the two of you guys indeed
but he's also the only person who could
tell me that and he doesn't really tell
me no for anything you know I'm still 34
year old man little brother or no he's
36 I can make my own decisions and none
of us have the tendency to ever do
anything that's really stupid
so at the peak who was funner to party
with
oh I've always been the finance
department
oh my gosh that's how I was introduced
to the Tates I saw a cheating party
it was someone it was someone in my
comments probably someone's still here
now I was like oh react to this video as
a cheating party I was triggered I was
very much triggered it was pretty funny
though we should react to it again I'm
still the phone on the party but today
no no don't worry about the peak I
haven't reached my Peak yet but I'm
still working on it I'm still working on
it yeah I'm the one Andrew I'm the kind
of guy I definitely take the party a bit
too far but give me an example go out to
the club there's five guys
15 girls we're all having fun world
partying Etc we'll come home and you'll
be like okay well this is the girl I'm
with I'm gonna go to bed it's 3am I know
I could go to bed with one of these
women at any one time back in my party
days I've I've
calmed down a bit on the womanizing I
really have uh and he'll be in bed at
three I'll still stay up till six
drinking with the guys because I think
let me squeeze the maximum amount of fun
out of this night as possible
so obviously it gets ruined when it gets
to six o'clock and the girl I like is
now asleep or home and it's like oh wait
well you know I definitely messed that
one up but I'll certainly try to have as
much fun as possible and it comes back
to bite me sometimes but when's the last
time you partied you've been in jail you
haven't had one day of Freedom no no
right you guys are known as these
kickboxing badass womanizing party guys
but Andrew's been very subdued he's
converted to Islam yeah he's not
drinking no he doesn't drink anymore you
had a fun night out of the Town a fun
night out on the town I don't know but I
had a fun night right here in my house
when my camera guy showed up I'm gonna
say his name his name's Bailey I'm gonna
say oh no I don't care if he wants to he
can't censor out don't give him
editorial control so he got here I
thought you know what Bailey's here
that's something new you know I've been
locked in jail now on my house arrest
let's open a bottle of champagne don't
worry baby just one four bottles of
champagne later Bailey's like wishing
for death I'm like you know okay I've
got to see but we stayed up all night
talking politics history very very
interesting things along with my my
coach my my physiotherapist Alex who
hates drinking by the way but he'll
he'll partake sometimes and you know it
was just three guys together talking
about I feel like it's the way things
should be and the way things certainly
were before mobile phones nowadays
everyone's too connected digitally they
speak to each other online too much
everyone WhatsApp to each other checks
on their friends that way I like sitting
around with my friends and just drinking
and talking and having a good time and
learning new things from them and
telling them new things that they don't
know I find that to be incredibly
fulfilling
so you were saying interest you said
Cutters you collect Cutters and all this
stuff I collect Cigar Lighters and cigar
accessories I'm a nerd about my cigars
I'm a real nerd about it I tried my
first cigar when I was 28 and now that I
smoke a lot of cigars people will accuse
me of saying oh well you try to teach
values but you encourage smoking I don't
encourage smoking these are bad for you
but if you do them screaming really hard
in the gym as fit and strong as possible
at least try to compensate the damage
but yeah I'm a nerd about my cigars I
smoked my first woman when I was 28 I
had a car crash which stopped me from
professionally fighting I had some
surgery just a year and a half ago to
fix all that damage finally but I
thought I can't fight anymore
put a one in the chat if you like cigars
one in the chat also guys like the video
we're at 156 likes there's 600 of you in
here I'm like it's free like the video
I've always thought cigars looked cool
I'd never smoked a cigarette or any kind
of tobacco product up until that point
and I walked into the Cigar Lounge I
thought oh look yeah this big Cuban
Scott let me buy one of these I had some
money even back then when I was 28 and I
got this cigar got about halfway through
and my head was spinning I don't know
how I drove home I felt horrible but
yeah now I smoke two three cigars A Day
Sometimes some days I'll go without
smoking but the accessories are what
make it cool you know even here on the
table these have been here since your uh
since your podcast with Andrew but it's
the lighters I like the Cutters I like
I'm a real nerd about it before going
out I'll pack my cigar cases except
we're ready for the club yeah what's
your preference what do you call it what
you go to a cigar cigar my favorite
cigar is actually so you have to liken
them to Champagne because most people
won't know what we're talking about if
we do cigars I'm gonna make it more
interesting people who don't know
champagne will say yeah some Dom
Perignon every single time I don't even
like champagne I don't like any
champagne but there are old Frenchmen
who know that there's a Verve Clique I'm
not a big drinker
but if I do it's got to be sweet it's
got to be like pure sugar
pure diabetes liquid diabetes that's it
I'm an American I am true to my roots of
obesity and diabetes
but we work out so it's all right that's
better than the Dom Perignon if it's the
right year Etc so with cigars everyone
goes Cohiba when you can buy Cubans when
you're outside the United States Cohiba
is a Dom Perignon of cigar it's got the
yellow label Everyone likes Cohibas but
this is not my favorite brand of cigar
but my favorite is H upman now they have
a European name even though they're
Cuban because a German businessman
started that company in 1848 Cohiba was
founded in 1966 it has much more history
behind the brand a much better quality
cigar in terms of build and flavor and
they're about half the price but me
smoking hate Joplin's is not a budgetary
decision I mean I'll buy cigars from the
1950s I smoke six seven thousand dollar
cigars just because I enjoy them but hey
Chapman are by far the best brand hands
down
can I give a quick shout out real quick
sure I only saw smoke cigars with two
people
their last name is either Tate
or sapala okay so shout out to Matt
sappal about this you're gonna love this
the finest of gentlemen the Tates and
the Apollo that's it that's a quick
shout out I I I very rarely smoke cigars
but if I do it's with the table well
actually in matsapola did a minute call
with uh Andrew last time I think using
my neck yeah and had a good conversation
together so uh going back to you uh
spiritually the take comes out Andrew
comes out recently announcing he's a
Muslim yeah right but in the podcast
with us he said you're you're still a
Christian yes what is that conversation
like between the two of you oh that's an
interesting question
all you have to understand if you are a
fan of Andrew who watches him on the
internet always converted to Islam
that's sudden it wasn't sudden it was a
journey that I saw him go on which
certainly lasted at least 10 11 months
up into the the day he converted
reverted according to Muslims I'll use
the proper terminology up until the day
he reverted I
became a Christian about six years ago I
spent a lot of my life as an atheist and
I'm so ashamed to say that I don't like
the word I think it's a bad word
nowadays because I was young and naive
and stupid enough I think that people
could be perfectly moral and live in a
perfect harmonious Society without the
need for religion and about six or seven
years ago I looked around the world
literally at what people were doing the
massive fetishization oh God I'll call
it of abortion
um you know the the degeneracy in
society and everyone's in it I literally
think the devil eats the left I
literally do because the stuff the stuff
they promote is literally what do they
say satanic satanic because it's like
you think about it all the stuff they
want they are literally they want to
play God they want to decide when babies
can be born they want to decide when
women
um can get pregnant they want to decide
when
um they want to promote policies that
take the father they're out of the home
they want to give mothers custody it's
like
the
all of the policies they promote are
evil I mean they want to turn women into
men and men into women like this this is
the policies of the left where it's like
you know I I don't want to say
Republicans but more conservative values
like we want policies that push families
like that is what we promote we want
family creation where the left just
literally wants the world to burn
are these my people and I was living in
Romania the amongst Orthodox Christian
country in the world my daughter's
maternal grandfather is actually an
Orthodox Christian priest and I picked
up the Bible again and I read it from
cover to cover front to back and that
was six years ago when I became a
Christian now ever since Andrew's
reversion
I have not spoken about my religious
beliefs because there are teams on
Twitter so you guys get the exclusive
there are literally warring tribes on
Twitter of Christian
Trolls let's call them and Muslim trolls
all fighting for my soul Tristan what do
you believe in Trista and I haven't
mentioned my religion ever since
Andrew's version of Islams there are
people who think I'm a Muslim there are
people who know I'm a Christian but
for me the values that are shared
between the two faiths are both contrary
to everything what Andrew would call The
Matrix is trying to shut down young
people's throats and try to program
people to believe
uh I think the days of of Christians and
Muslims murdering each other in Crusades
and um you know trying to take the holy
holy city of Jerusalem Etc are over I
think that there are ideological
differences and there are ignorant
Christians who will be like oh yeah but
you know Islam's a fake religion but
then there are ignorant Muslims who'll
say oh Christianity is a fake religion
good you're supposed to think that
they're different religions and they do
teach different things they have
different Messengers and they have
slightly different messages but as a
whole I'm perfectly happy living at a
house when my brother is a Muslim
because one I respect this decision two
I understand why he reverted three I
understand that we have a common enemy
in
uh we have an enemy in common and we
have the exact same goals I feel like
the religions now should be closer than
ever before it's fine to say you believe
things you know it's interesting there's
a huge War too between like Christians
and Catholics like Protestants and cats
it's so interesting religion people will
fight about like the hardest
over everything which I guess is
probably I don't say a good thing but it
makes sense right it's over who's the
creator of the world but
it's interesting because even Catholics
and Christians where I would say we're
more similar than Muslims and Christians
yeah there's been whole Wars over the
slight differences that we have I don't
and I believe things about God that you
don't but can we at least
agree that this is wrong and I feel like
Common Ground would unite Christians and
Muslims hand in hand if people were less
standoffish so I have no problem with my
brother being a Muslim he's quit
drinking I have lost my drinking partner
and the only reason I'm actually talking
to you about religion and answering
these questions because I kept it very
close to my heart and I haven't spoken
to anybody about it it's because I am
publicly drinking whiskey well so you
need a new drinking Partnerships and I
can help you out here absolutely and
you're Jewish yes
Muslims refer to Christians and Jews as
people of the book that you have to
understand that Muslims hold Christians
in in very high regard so I've read even
since getting out of jail I've read four
books on Islam since getting out of jail
and I was actually quizzed by a Muslim
scholar who lives in the united
refer to Islam
and I said to him I said reversion or
conversion to any religion I don't
believe it's something that you do I
believe it's something that happens to
you if you look into a subject and you
read about you read the Bible and you
read about you know Christianity and you
read about the life do you think he'll
convert
or Reaver whatever it is no you don't
think so
he's like you know what yes screw it I'm
a Christian I feel like it's something
that would have to happen to me not
something I choose to do and I've even
had people say oh you know your life
would be better if you revert to Islam
because
um you know there'd be benefits of you
living in the Middle East Etc I said no
no how disingenuous would that be to my
Muslim friends and colleagues of which I
have many to revert for any beneficial
reason other than me genuinely feeling
it within my soul
so that's the reason I haven't not
because I haven't chosen to but because
it hasn't happened to me right so that
means it could happen yeah absolutely
right absolutely you said it's so
interesting you just said something
earlier real cool real brief you tweeted
out you said positive pregnancy test
question mark yes unsure what to do this
is the sign you were looking for keep
the baby yes raise the baby by the time
they are two you will thank God you read
this and shudder that you ever
considered an abortion I understand you
have a choice but make the right one yes
I did tweet that because I understand
that there is now a chance with 1.8
million people following me on Twitter
and five six hundred and seven thousand
hundred thousand people watching each of
my tweets that I may have just saved a
life
I wasn't trying to make any point about
the legality of abortion because
everyone's arguing underneath the Tweet
oh it should be legal it should be
illegal I will actually upset both teams
because I'm not pro-life or pro-choice I
believe that abortion should be legal
under many circumstances and there are
many reasons why no no
ban it ban it
no should be legal I'm like a I'm a
die-hard pro oh that's kind of ironic a
Die Hard pro-lifer people there are
people in the world who for many reasons
would need an abortion what I do is I
don't try to force my views on anyone
else so my view on abortion is very
simple I'm against abortion for me I've
made lots lots of money I'm a smart guy
I'm a great dad if I get some girl
pregnant even if it's by accident it was
my choice to sleep with her and I'm
gonna make sure she brings that baby
into the world and take care of it for
the rest of its life so I'm against it
for me I don't try to force my views on
other people because otherwise we're
going to start this whole debate it's
going to happen in the comments section
of this video but what if a woman gets
raped and I'm against abortion being
used as a form of contraception so I'm
on neither team so both teams can get
mad at me and I don't really care I just
thought with so many followers maybe
maybe and that how crazy it was that one
out of three women has had an abortion
isn't that nuts one out of three
like you cannot tell me and the worst
part is out of that I'm like 40 have had
two or more abortions you can't tell me
that's not birth control
it's just like lady how many how many
times we got to do this I'm gonna get a
letter in the mail in 17 years time from
somebody whose mother's gonna tell them
the story of the time she read Tristan
Tate's tweet and I thought that would be
awesome wow so that was my motivation I
wasn't trying to start a political
argument because I really don't care
enough about these issues to debate
people on them
because I know how I want to live my
life and if you're a crack addict on the
streets of New York and you end up
pregnant through sex work I do believe
there is a case where you personally
don't need to be bringing a baby into
the world so I'm not going to tell you
it's illegal so I'm in the middle so
everyone can be mad at me everyone can
hate me do you like the bit
oh I love debates you like it as much as
he likes the way it's oh I love debates
okay so you love the boots okay so
politically uh you know when you when
you think about like are you following
politics closely do you watch the
election do you following the election
closely I do I do yes what do you look
what do you think about the elections in
the U.S right now and the conditions in
U.S politically Jesus I feel like
both teams have
psychos that they need to Pander to to
the point where the whole process has
become absolutely ridiculous I feel like
the right have fewer psychos who are
less extreme
I'm not going to say what gender the
psychos are
I'm not going to say it
I'm not going to say who they both have
to Pander to
I'm not going to say it I'm not going to
say what policies
they have to push towards
but if I had to say it
women
yep yep women
than the left but you take people who
say very normal things and again this is
going to get me in trouble like men
can't get pregnant and people who've
been alive since the 1950s since the
1960s people who know that's not true
now have to pretend that they think it
is true and I'm like I'm not going to go
into what you think about foreign policy
I'm not going to go into what you think
about the issues America is facing
because you just said men can get
pregnant so you're an idiot and I feel
like the pandering to all these special
groups whether it be the the
military-industrial complex that's not
must not go down that road
um or you know the the insane I won't
say the lgbtq and say people I'll say
the QT plus people because I think LGB
and QT plus should be completely
separate things
um yeah it's very hard to take any
American politician seriously I do know
who I want to be the next person of the
United States you probably know who I
want to be the next person
[Laughter]
oh yeah
um
I was going to say
the audience doesn't know this when you
walk in here there's a uh is it six feet
or eight feet painting of President Joe
Biden I was so impressed the fact that
you guys have that kind of Pride for us
in the house well you know I'm not very
good at darts so I need a big board
would you say you were born in America I
was born in the United States raised in
the UK I'm English I consider yourself I
would consider myself English British
I'm proud to be English I love English
History as a mixed race person I like to
be able to stand up and say I'm very
proud of British history we should all
be proud of our heritage without people
being able to point the finger at me and
call me a racist because when white
English people say that suddenly they're
racist for some reason uh yeah super
proud to be British I think that the
influence that the British have had on
the world is incalculably larger than
almost any other culture
um please correct me if I'm wrong um a
lot of the Great Inventions in the world
were British uh the way that you go to
every single country in the world and
they're all speaking the language of one
tiny Island in northern Europe why you
know it's it's I'm a proud Englishman
and I don't care about the United States
so much because I left when I was eight
years old if you want a guaranteed way
to get in touch with me maybe you have a
business idea maybe you want some
fashion tips maybe you just want to
connect you could find me on my neckt
how how interested can I be as much as
I'm interested in the nerdy way that
I'll follow it and know what each team
has to think if I've never worked a job
in America I've never had a girlfriend
in America I'm not educated by the
American school system I don't have a
business in the United States never had
an American girlfriend oh no I've had
loads but
[Laughter]
I've never had to manage a relationship
while living in the United States so um
how much what do I really have invested
in who wins the election you know as
much as I'm interested in it I consider
myself British and I care much more
about it I don't even know what goes on
in British politics
I literally have no idea which is a lot
more up than the United States in
lots of ways it's failing in every
single metric which makes me sad would
you say you follow British politics even
more than American people no I fear
American politics because it's more
interesting the British politicians are
all all rubbish and because of the
electoral system where the Prime
Minister comes from the party who has
the most seats and each seat is an
individual election with the first pass
the post system there's no winners
nobody nobody can come along as a hero
let's say hypothetically because I don't
wanna I don't want to say who I support
for president but let's say
hypothetically some billionaire
businessman with Charisma came along and
said I want to become the leader of
England he's got no chance he'd have to
start his own political party he'd lose
in every single individual election oh I
didn't know that principal constituency
in the United
Kingdom and you'd never hear from them
again I think it was in 19
I don't want to say the exact day
because someone's going to correct me on
it but it was in the 1970s the green
party of England won 20 something
percent of the vote and got zero seats
in the House of Parliament that's the
way the system works there so no hero is
coming along to save the UK which is sad
because I feel like both political
parties that could possibly win and both
their leaders are equally horrible what
you're saying is only in America yeah
exactly something like that possible
yeah exactly anyone you've got two dead
horses and the race is about to start
why watch I'm not interested and nobody
else is either I actually have another
question for you so we all have our
nicknames right yeah
pbd right stop your brothers Cobra tape
you
are the Talisman yeah okay I thought it
was Tales man it's like always how I was
pronouncing it I actually had to Google
what the Talisman was right so it is a
an object
that has magic power and brings good
luck yeah right and keeps evil away and
protects
the person wearing it from illness
accident disgrace and Misfortune
absolutely right so how did you get the
name the Talisman and are you Andrews
Talisman I absolutely am but it wasn't
Andrew who gave you the nickname I was
17 years old and I was working at a
sandwich shop and I used to hang around
with this African guy from the Ivory
Coast Republic Luke if you're watching
God bless you I don't know where you are
today
and we go out to various bars and we
would um anytime he'd see attractive
women because I mean I'm 17 what do you
know you know of course I'm out there
trying to be women
and every time there was a group of
attractive women I go over and approach
him and I wasn't I mean how smooth can a
17 year old be but you know girls tended
to like me and he called me his talisman
I I don't know if it was his
his lack of English that made him use
the word Talisman instead of good luck
charm but he would also call me his
Talisman and it was the Talisman and
that stuck and then I needed the fight
name and it was Tristan the Talisman
Tate and I feel like if you are my
friend if I truly care about you whether
you are pursuing a new goal in business
whether you are attacked on the street
having me by your side is a I'm a good
person to have by your side and I've
proven that hundreds of times to every
single person who I hold dear so I like
that name because it suits who I am you
know I say that in every single photo if
you see me and Andrew together I'm
always walking behind him and believe me
I'll hit someone faster than the
bodyguards with us will I'm that guy so
I like the nickname and I think it suits
me very well
guys I gotta get ready for the show
sorry I was a little bit mesmerized by
this reaction and
add as much as I'd like but thank you
for watching guys like the video on your
way out um I thought that
I thought it was really interesting to
learn more about Tristan just because
we've all heard so much about Andrew
um
you can definitely
you can definitely see how their
mindsets are really similar and I think
it's actually really cool how
um I guess just the mindset they have on
family I think that's really lost in
society today but let me know what you
guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time